[Music]
rafe heard a muffled thump on the carpet
of the front hall
and glanced up from the jigsaw puzzle he
was working on
what's that mary his wife's shuffling
footsteps receded then approached
and she appeared in the doorway of his
study her chubby fingers closed around a
thick manila envelope
it's for you she said stepping into the
room reluctantly and holding it out to
him
he took it and waited for mary to leave
but she just stood there
her round face shining rafe sighed
inwardly and inspected the outside of
the envelope
there was no return address but it was
postmarked from the city
sliding a fingernail under the sealed
flap he tore a great gash in the top
then pried the envelope open and peered
into the dark interior
what is it mary's eyes were piggish and
glistening
stack of papers looks like rafe tipped
the package to one side
letting the loose pile fall into his
hand
the second he had registered the
contents of the top page he felt the
blood freezing in his veins
the shock seemed to last an eternity but
finally
aware of mary's curious gaze he replaced
the stack in the envelope
fighting to keep his expression neutral
it's nothing
he said his throat so dry he nearly
coughed the words
she was still looking at him it's just
insurance stuff you know
he added lamely huh mary looked down at
the envelope in his hands
then back up at his face without a word
she turned and disappeared down the hall
he heard dishes banging around in the
kitchen a few seconds later
ray fled out a long slow breath dropping
the envelope on top of the half-finished
puzzle on his desk
he scrubbed at his unshaven cheeks with
both hands
what if i hadn't been here he thought
what if she had opened it
he tried to calm his racing heart and
nearly succeeded
the fact was that he had been here and
mary hadn't opened the envelope
and he was getting all worked up over
nothing besides he told himself
even if she had opened it she probably
wouldn't have understood the
significance of what was inside
he sat down at his desk again moving the
envelope aside for a moment so he could
study the puzzle once more
and try to regain his focus rafe was
keen on puzzles and he particularly
liked this one
he'd bought it online one of a specialty
series called predators and prey
it depicted a wolf captured in mid-air
preparing to sink its outstretched claws
into the flank of a running elk
rafe had worked a few of the other
puzzles in the series
one pictured a crocodile taking down a
wildebeest
one a lioness sinking her teeth into the
jugular of a gazelle
and one a great white tearing a seal in
half
these three were already framed and
hanging over the mantle
putting the puzzles together gave him a
great if not entirely understood
satisfaction
he felt as though he was building nature
establishing the relationships between
its creatures
playing god in a sense he had always
identified himself with the predators in
the pictures of course
sleek and deadly and captivating he
glanced over at the envelope he
just received its arrival made him feel
more and more in the position of the
prey
the elk the gazelle the seal the
wildebeest
it was a position he didn't care to be
in
rafe got abruptly to his feet snatching
his car keys from the peg on the wall
behind him
he leaned out into the hallway i have to
run to the store mary do you need
anything
there was a long silence and rafe
thought she wasn't going to answer him
the moody [ __ ] but then her voice
floated down the hall
maybe a gallon of milk and some of those
rolls like we had
don't be long dinner's almost ready i'll
be as long as i please and as long as it
takes
rafe thought smoothing his hand across
the wolf's proud laminated head
he picked the envelope up feeling as
though it weighed several pounds more
than it had when he'd first handled it
then secured it inside his jacket
pulling the zipper up until the bulging
brown paper was completely concealed
keys jangling from his fist rafe made
his way toward the front door and sidled
out into the dusk
he drove to a rundown motel on the
outskirts of town
and parked in a space at the back of one
of the buildings in between the glow
from the flickering
lights there was no one around that he
could see but his skin
still crawled with a sensation of being
watched with a trembling hand he reached
up and flicked on the dome light
the envelope sat on the passenger seat
its contours innocuous he noticed now
that the handwriting on the front was
formal
almost fussy the letters decorated with
unneeded swirls and flourishes
reef imagined someone whether man or
woman he couldn't determine
sitting at a desk very like his own
perhaps with an equally precious quill
pen
gripped between his or her fingers
copying his address onto the envelope
who was this person how did he know
where rafe lived or even know his name
rafe's head was beginning to pound and
he wished he had stopped for a couple of
aspirin on his way out of the house
he considered driving to a convenience
store to buy some but then he realized
he was simply putting off the inevitable
he drew in a very long breath through
his nose then exhaled through his mouth
he snatched up the envelope in both
hands and slid out the papers
all in one thoughtless motion the image
on top
the one that had so startled him before
showed a woman
or what had once been a woman her naked
body had been torn into four roughly
equal pieces
that swam in a pool of spreading blood
shredded clothing and flesh
the photograph was black and white so
the blood looked more like tar
rafe's heart rate was soaring again and
he paused to contain it
he held the photo up to the light to
examine it more closely
just between the woman's clavicles in
the pale skin where the neck met the
chest
was a dark smear that bore a more
deliberate shape than a blood stain
rafe stared at it knowing what it was
yet compelled to investigate further
his emotions were a confusing tangle of
guilt of arousal
of fear at being found out and of
something else
something that felt almost like pride he
brought the photo even closer to his
face
the mark was a brand seared into the
woman's flesh
the skin was blackened and bubbled
around the edges
the shape was that of an animal's paw
print a pad and four toes with long
sharp claws
rafama smiled as he looked at it but
then he stopped himself
suddenly peering out of the car windows
into the dimness the feeling of being
observed almost unbearable
he squinted but again he saw no one
only mildly comforted ray flipped
through the rest of the pile which were
all
similarly themed black and white
photographs he paused to consider each
one
briefly remembering every photo depicted
a woman in a differing state of
mutilation
some were torn apart as the first woman
was some were disemboweled
some merely missing limbs or heads all
lay situated in outdoor wooded areas
leaned against trees or peeking out of
shrubbery
all bore the exact same brand of the
animal's paw
rafe's trembling had increased as he
progressed through the stack
which numbered about 50 images at first
he thought a member of the police
department must have sent them
because some of them were similar to the
crime scene photos that had turned up in
the newspapers
but other pictures portrayed victims
that were still undiscovered
and that fact pointed to something else
blackmail
reef's suspicions were heightened by the
piece of paper hidden at the bottom of
the pile of photos
in the same frilly handwriting that
graced the envelope another address had
been written across a clean sheet of
cream-colored vellum
there was no name but the address was in
the city quite nearby
on a street that rafe had driven down a
few times
suddenly his fear and paranoia boiled
over into rage
and he crumpled the paper in his fist
which he then banged on the dashboard
repeatedly
someone had been following him someone
knew everything
even the location of the bodies the
police hadn't found out about yet
and now this someone clearly wanted rafe
to come to him to make some sort of
arrangement
his fist had started to hurt and he let
it drop into his lap
rafe's eyes narrowed yes he could
certainly arrange something he thought
he could even make this clever
blackmailer the star of one of the
photographs he seemed to like so much
rafama smiled again but then his brow
furrowed what if he was being set up
it would be immensely stupid to waltz
right into the blackmailer's lair
where cops or worse could be lying and
wait for him
then again if he didn't go then the
blackmailer would surely send the photos
and his address to the cops anyway
the pounding in rafe's head grew more
intense threatening to blot out rational
thought altogether
he tossed the pictures back in the
envelope and threw the package back onto
the passenger seat
pinching the bridge of his nose with one
hand the paper with the blackmailer's
address was still clutched in his fist
and when the pain subsided enough so
that he could see clearly again
he pulled it out and unscrewed it
smoothing it against the steering wheel
he felt pinned like a dead butterfly to
a board
whatever he did he was going to be the
prey the weakling
and being weak was something he never
allowed himself he would have to think
hard
find some way of gaining an advantage
staring down at the address on the paper
he committed every last black scroll to
memory
then folded the page calmly and inserted
it back into the envelope
mary would be wondering where he was and
he still had to stop at the store on the
way back
so as not to arouse her suspicions
further tonight he would go home
eat dinner with his wife pretend nothing
was wrong
he would wait until mary went to her
bridge game after dinner
and then he would destroy the photos
after that he would lie on his bed in
the dark listening to the tick of the
clock and the thump and hum of the
refrigerator
and he would think what he was going to
do to make sure that he remained the
predator in his present situation
and when tomorrow morning came he would
head straight for the address in the
city
his head clear his nerves composed he
would be sure to bring his branding iron
along
just in case rafe had cruised up and
down the street five times
and he still couldn't see the number of
the building he was looking for
as he took another turn around the block
he began to panic
after all he had destroyed the paper
with the address along with all the
photographs
he'd burn them in the fireplace in his
study watching as the edges curled and
disappeared as smoke up the flu
but he was sure he'd remembered the
number correctly and that damn number
just wasn't here
he made another jerky u-turn and drove
down the street again
going too fast at first but then forcing
himself to slow down and look harder
luckily it was a sunday
and the streets between the high rises
were nearly deserted
finally on his seventh pass he pulled
the car hard to the curb
cursing and savagely scraping the gears
as he shoved it into park
someone was [ __ ] with him he realized
and when he found out who it was he was
going to make that person
suffer more than anyone had ever
suffered for a moment he lost himself in
his revenge fantasy
picturing himself yanking out toenails
with rusty pliers
inserting needles under eyelids the
images were so vivid he could almost see
them through the sun-stained windshield
superimposed over the languid
storefronts outside
at last he shook his head trying to
dislodge the visions
this was definitely not helping he
stared out the windows a few more
minutes
breathing hard and reading the numbers
over and over to himself
finally giving up in frustration
suddenly hungry he lurched out of the
car
and headed for a hole-in-the-wall burger
joint that was sending irresistible
odors of frying meat into the rippling
autumn air
once inside he ordered a large burger
with everything and a strawberry
milkshake
carrying his booty out into the street
letting it drip through the wax paper as
he ate
when he had wolfed down the sandwich and
slurped the last of the milkshake from
the bottom of the styrofoam cup
he stuffed his trash into the barrel
near the edge of the sidewalk
wiping the grease from his hands onto
his jeans
the food had only served to make him
angrier more frustrated
the meat sat like a lead ball in his
stomach
rafe was heading back to the car
thinking he was just going to pack it
all in
go home and hope for the best when he
saw something he hadn't noticed on any
of his previous passes
it was a storefront directly across the
street from where he'd parked the car
really just a tiny narrow window and an
even tinier door
he would have put money on the fact that
it hadn't been there when he'd looked
before
but then again it was a small place
crammed in between a wig store that
looked as though no one had entered it
since the beehive was still in style
and a specialty bakery with a window
full of towering pink and white wedding
cakes
the peeling numbers over the dust coated
door matched the address on the paper in
the envelope
his hands curling into fists rafe began
marching across the road
forgetting all the careful planning he'd
done forgetting the fact that he might
be walking into a trap
he mounted the sidewalk on the opposite
curb leaning forward like a heat-seeking
missile
his forehead cutting a path through the
air
he grabbed the handle of the door of the
little shop and shoved
barely hearing the pleasant little
tinkle of the bell above the entrance
the blood in his veins felt hot pulsing
into every atom of his body
for a moment he could see nothing the
shop was dark compared to the late
morning sunshine outside
rafe stopped and blinked a few times
getting his bearings
pricking up his ears for any sound of
ambush he heard nothing except for the
echo of the bell over the door
and a slight scraping sound like glass
bottles being pushed together
may i help you at the sound of the voice
ray froze
but then his vision resolved itself the
person who had spoken was across the
room
standing behind a tall wooden counter
that made him appear much shorter than
he probably was
the man was fairly young but with a face
bearing the strong character of age
his skin was the color of coffee and his
abundant black hair was pulled back in a
neat ponytail
he was looking up at rafe with very
large nearly black eyes
and his expression was one of bemused
expectation
rafe pulled himself up to his full
height which was well over six feet
and advanced on the front counter you
know who i
am he said in his most threatening growl
it wasn't exactly a question
nor was it a statement of fact what are
you playing at
rafe glanced around the shop as though
looking for the accomplices he was
certain must be hiding in the shadows
he hadn't noticed it until now but the
store looked like something out of the
19th century
the shelves lining the walls contained
murky brown glass bottles with yellowed
labels
their contents unidentifiable there was
an odd chemical tang in the air
something like musk and sulfur with a
hint of some exotic spice
what is this place can i get you
anything
the man smoothly ignored rave's question
straightening up the bottles on the
counter in front of him
to one side there was also an
old-fashioned scale one that looked like
the astrological symbol for libra
everything seemed covered with a thick
layer of undisturbed dust
i've got some tea in the back if you'd
like some
rafe had not sat down and was still
towering menacingly over the counter
i don't want any damn tea i want to know
what's going on here
why did you send me those pictures the
man held up one hand
his fingers were oddly long and spindly
let's not get ahead of ourselves
first things first i know who you are of
course
rafe g letorno known to police and the
tabloid press as the wolfman
or more commonly the jackal although
you're not actually known to the police
are you mr litorno not yet you bastard
if you think you can blackmail me
the man shook his head chuckling no no
you have things all wrong
here please sit down and i'll get some
tea and we'll talk everything over
i'm sure we can come to a reasonable
understanding
rafe reached out and grabbed the man's
arm but he didn't even flinch
the muscles under his flesh felt like
solid granite rafe let go confused
well who are you then the man's eyes
glittered
i'm called sekha mempet not that it's of
any consequence at this juncture
rafe snorted what kind of name is that
egyptian
actually now if you'll excuse me for
just a moment
the man slipped from behind the counter
and threw a wooden door
every move silent and graceful rafe had
hardly registered his absence before the
man returned bearing a tray
containing a silver teapot and two
delicate china cups
the steam from the pot emitted the same
spicy odor that rafe had noticed earlier
it was a heady scent pleasant and just
the slightest bit sinister
making him feel as though he had
ingested a very low dose of lsd
he shook his head trying to clear it and
attempted to fasten back onto his rage
the attempt was only partially
successful
now then sekhem sat on an unseen stool
behind the counter
and began pouring the rich liquid into
the cups he set one in front of rafe
then smiled again his face was strong
and handsome
but there was something strange about it
that rafe couldn't quite place
it scared him a little though he was
reluctant to admit as much
i did send you the pictures to get you
to come here that's true
sekhem said taking a sip of his tea and
i do know all about your activities of
the past several years
i don't wish to disclose how i
discovered your secret but all of that
doesn't matter
i'm aware that you think i brought you
here to ask for money but i assure you
that is not my intention
in fact he said lowering his head to
look around underneath the counter
i brought you here to give you something
what is it rafe instinctively reached
for his pocket
where he usually kept a weapon of some
sort but then he remembered he'd left
all his equipment in the car
stupid just a moment sekhim was
rummaging through what sounded like more
glass bottles mumbling to himself
ah here it is he raised up with a small
gold box
resting in his long fingered hand he set
it on the counter and slid it across a
rafe
don't open it until you get home please
what's in there
rafe had started to sweat and the tea
was making him feel drowsy
well you'll find out when you get home
won't you second's black
eyes considered him with something like
amusement or perhaps pity
think of it as a second chance not many
people get one of those
rafe felt really bizarre now almost as
though he was floating outside of
himself
watching the whole scene unfold from
above what are you talking about
even his voice sounded far away like the
hum of a distant radio signal
redemption mr letorno sekhem said
and the word seemed to echo through
rafe's head as though through a massive
canyon
the man smiled once again his white
teeth glowing in the gathering dimness
until the smile was all that remained a
cheshire cat grin
hanging in the air before rafe's face
growing larger and larger
until it blotted out all other reality
rafe started awake in his bed pain
screaming in his chest
as though his heart had just attempted a
brute force escape through his rib cage
moonlight streamed across the sheets and
mary was a snoring lump beside him
her face squashed against her pillow one
flaccid breast peeking from her tattered
yellow nightgown
he waited until his nerves had ceased
their jangling and then he slid out from
beneath the covers
wincing at the creeks of the bedsprings
as he swung his legs over the side of
the mattress
mary stirred and turned away from him
but didn't awaken
once he was out in the hallway with the
bedroom door safely closed behind him
rafe walked more normally making his way
down the stairs and through the kitchen
where he stopped to grab a beer from the
fridge
the glowing blue numbers on the
microwave read 4 36 am
reef drained half the beer bottle in one
gulp trying to dislodge the memory of
that horrible dream he'd been having
he almost thought he could still see the
full mouth of white teeth hanging in the
air before him
and there were other things too weren't
there things he'd seen just before
waking up
shadows gathering in the corners of his
vision even though he was fully awake
now he still
felt disoriented what day was it had he
really gone downtown to look for that
shop
or had that all been part of the dream
the pictures had been real hadn't they
suddenly uncertain rafe carried his beer
into the study switching on the overhead
light which also caused the ceiling fan
to wheeze into life
rustling some papers on his desk and
dislodging the thin film of dust that
had settled on his unfinished puzzle
picking up the iron poker he raked
through the coals in the fireplace
not sure if he was hoping to find
evidence of the photographs or find
nothing
in which case he was seriously losing
his mind
but no there was a singed fragment of a
manila envelope and a curled corner of
what looked like photographic paper
so at least that much of the scenario
had been no dream
rafe drank another pull of his beer and
then sat down heavily behind his desk
if the whole trip to the shop had been
his imagination then that still meant
that he would have to deal with the
problem
and after the dream the idea seemed less
than encouraging
he felt very tired suddenly not like he
wanted to go back to sleep because he
knew he probably couldn't
but bone tired exhausted a feeling of
being unable to continue with anything
because it all seemed like too much
trouble even the proud wolf on the desk
before him seemed to be mocking him
daring him to finish what he had started
he put his hand to the edge of the
puzzle
meaning to sweep it all off the desk in
a dramatic fashion
but in the end his hand simply dropped
to his side
after a long moment of sitting thus rafe
finally stirred
it occurred to him that the branding
iron the one with the animal paw the one
he'd made himself expressly for the
purpose of making a mark on his prey
might not be in its usual place he
remembered putting it in the car this
morning before he had gone on his
possibly imaginary errand
had he really put it there he couldn't
start losing track of things like that
he had always been so meticulous so
careful that was one of the ways he'd
prevented mary from knowing anything for
all these years
reaching beneath the desk rafe slit
aside a small false panel in the wood
tripping a switch that he'd installed
himself he opened the middle drawer and
lifted out the piles of meaningless
papers
revealing a secret compartment at the
bottom
in the glow from the overhead light he
could clearly see that the branding iron
was in its proper place
and he let out his breath but then he
noticed
pushed far back in the compartment a
glint of gold
trembling he reached inside it was the
box
he wasn't sure whether to be relieved or
horrified so he settled for an even mix
of the two
his fingers skittered across the smooth
surface of the box
feeling its scornful dimensions before
grabbing it and pulling it out into the
light
as he brought it up to his face he
thought he caught a whiff of the scent
from the shop
dust and spicy tea and sulfur the silken
coffee colored skin of sekhim and pet
shimmered in his mind's eye for a moment
before vanishing into fragments
the box was light in his hand small
enough to sit comfortably in the palm
think of it as a second chance he heard
the mysterious man say
and for a second he almost thought the
man was in the room with him
breathing down his neck his skin crawled
but he refused to turn around to look
he hated himself for acting like a
frightened child
with one savage movement rafe seized the
top of the box and pulled it away
flinging it across the desk he stared
down at what was inside
sitting there on a bed of thin cotton
was a small white feather
rafal almost laughed sitting back in his
desk chair and plucking the feather out
of the box
turning it this way and that under the
light what the hell did this mean
the feather was as ordinary as could be
presumably taken from a dove or perhaps
even a pigeon
was this some foreigner's idea of a joke
if so
rafe didn't get it disgusted he dropped
the feather back into the box
closed the lid and tossed the whole
affair back into the secret compartment
of his drawer
then he leaned his elbows on his desk
pressing his fingers to his temples
he certainly didn't need this [ __ ]
especially from someone who knew so much
about him
if the guy was telling the truth that he
didn't want money then what exactly did
he want
and how did he expect rafe to be able to
figure it out
he gnashed his teeth and sat up straight
again first thing in the morning he was
going right back to that shop downtown
if that creepy egyptian bastard couldn't
cough up a decent explanation
or even if he could rafe was going to
fix him the police would never find all
the pieces
smiling broadly ray flicked off the
overhead light and headed back upstairs
he might be able to sleep a few more
hours after all
dawn had not quite broken when rafe woke
again this time slowly
seeing the darkened bedroom coming into
hazy focus around him
mary was still sleeping now splayed on
her back
her mouth hanging crookedly open
a dream had not awakened rafe this time
but something far more primal
something he recognized right away maybe
it was the stress of receiving the
pictures
the feeling of being in some predator's
sights that triggered that familiar
hunger
but whatever it was it was eating him
alive
he slid out of bed again feeling the
urgency knowing he'd have to work
quickly before
full daylight arrived grabbing a flannel
shirt and jeans from the closet
he hurried downstairs and dressed in the
kitchen his heart hammering in his chest
mary should sleep for at least another
hour or two she didn't have to go to
work until nine
rafe thought he'd have plenty of time to
go out satiate his need
come back here grab a shower and stop by
sekhim's shop before
his own work shift started at two but
he'd have to work fast
foregoing breakfast or even a cup of
coffee rafe slipped into his shoes
stopped in his office to retrieve his
branding iron and a few other things
and went out wincing at the roar his car
made when it started up
the sky overhead was a medium purple
with pink fingers just starting to reach
up from the horizon
at first he felt befuddled unsure at
where to find someone on such short
notice
but then his predator instincts kicked
in erasing all uncertainty from his mind
he backed the car out of the driveway
and headed east his hands firm on the
steering wheel
he only passed a few cars as he cruised
toward town
his headlights cutting a swath in the
grayish dimness before him
the sidewalks were nearly deserted other
than a pair of drunks supporting each
other and giggling
and a burly man in a hard hat carrying a
black lunch box
heading for a rig parked in a vacant lot
on the side of the road
sensing prey might be near rafe slowed
the car down to 30
letting his gaze rove from left to right
for a mile or two he saw no one
but then just down the street from a
closed-up strip mall
he spotted a perfect catch a slight
woman in a nurse's uniform
sitting alone at a bus stop her nose
pressed against the morning paper
rafe's veins thrummed beneath his skin
but he kept his cool
not wanting to alarm his potential
victim
he pulled the car smoothly to the curb
just ahead of the bus stop and turned
off the engine
moving slowly with a casual grace he got
out of the car and ambled toward the bus
stop
excuse me he said when he was still
several yards away
what time's the bus come he smiled his
hands stuffed in his pockets
the woman looked up and smiled back
somewhat distractedly
she glanced at her watch about 10
minutes i guess
oh i'm supposed to pick someone up rafe
made no move toward the bench
remaining on the sidewalk a decent
distance from her
she nodded and went back to her paper
and rafe cheered inwardly
knowing she didn't see him as a threat
he kept his hands in his pockets walking
in little circles
looking at his feet but all the time
keeping his gaze on her furtively
she was a nice looking woman a bit older
than he liked but still slim
and pretty with dark hair pulled back in
a tight bun
and a high aristocratic forehead he
couldn't see much of her body underneath
the scrubs
but her legs looked long and the skin on
her arms was firm and pale
after a few minutes he made his way
slowly toward her
say do you happen to have a cigarette
she looked up and smiled again
still unwary sorry i don't smoke
i'm trying to quit myself he moved
closer whistling through his teeth
as if it was the most natural thing in
the world he would have to strike soon
before the bus rounded the corner
he couldn't take the chance that it
might be early languidly he leaned
against the side of the bus shelter his
hands still in his pockets
going to be hot today he said yes
the woman was skimming the paper
apparently not listening to him
sure is rafe took one last long glance
at the sky
and then he turned and was on her moving
so quickly that an observer would have
seen nothing but a blur
his arms locked around her like an iron
maiden his big hand clamped over her
mouth
don't struggle he hissed in her ear i'm
just going to take you for a little ride
she shook her head and pushed against
him but she was small
no match for his size or strength he
dragged her off the bench almost
carrying her
keeping her body pressed close to his so
that anyone passing would only see two
lovers walking down the street in each
other's arms
the newspaper fluttered to the sidewalk
as he marched his prey toward the car
parked at the curb
he shoved her into the passenger seat
where she immediately clawed for the
door handle
looking for escape stay where you are
rafe said calmly
he had retrieved his revolver from
beneath the driver's seat and was
pointing it at her stomach
her eyes grew very big and rafe could
almost see the thoughts whirring around
in her head
wondering if she could jump out the door
before he could pull the trigger
he smiled at her and the flurry in her
eyes died down
she would be docile like the good prey
she was
he drove her toward the highway where
the buildings and housing developments
thinned out somewhat
she begged and cried at first offering
him money swearing not to report him
but after a while she saw that he was
not going to acknowledge her and she
quieted down
her hands trembled in her lap rafe took
his victim only a few miles
mindful of the time factor he turned at
an exit ramp off the highway
one that led only to a group of disused
looking gas stations and cd motor lodges
morning traffic had begun to pick up
rafe kept to the speed limit
trying not to attract attention one of
the motels
a pink stucco affair with a sign so
faded that rafe couldn't read it
had only two cars in the parking lot he
steered toward it then pulled around to
the side of the building
there was a small cops of woods in the
back and as luck would have it the
chain-link fence that divided it from
the motel's grounds looked loose
he waved the gun at the woman we're
going to get out now
don't make any noise or try to run the
woman did as she was told and rafe
followed close behind her
casting a wary eye around to make sure
no one was watching them from the
windows
all the curtains in the motel rooms were
drawn and still
he pushed her through a ragged slit in
the fence and he poked the gun in her
ribs when she scratched her hand on the
metal and whimpered
he came through after her the link
rattling but hopefully not enough to
awaken anyone nearby
he didn't take her far into the trees
before forcing her to stop
take off your clothes he ordered and she
did it her face contorted in terror and
shame
she was crying but they were silent
tears rafe was almost proud of her
she did have a nice body under the
scrubs taut and trim
and ray fell on her with animal abandon
forcing himself between her legs
she gasped and he pressed the gun to her
temple reminding her to keep quiet
tiny sounds snuffled out from between
her tightly closed lips
and snot was running down her cheeks it
felt good but it was over too quickly
when rafe had finished he yanked his
jeans back up without buttoning them
staring down at the naked woman writhing
in the dirt
as he looked at her he remembered the
wolf in the puzzle frozen forever in the
moment of attack
time for him seemed to slow down and
finally stop
and he reveled in the feeling of eternal
invincibility as he stood over his
victim
who probably could have got up and run
away but of course wouldn't think of
doing that
she was a good little gazelle who would
lie there and take what was coming to
her
at last almost as an afterthought he
pulled a gutting knife from his boot and
began
slicing starting at her throat so she
would be immediately silenced
her eyes were still huge with surprise
and confusion
not understanding how this nice man who
had pulled up at the bus stop and asked
her for a cigarette could be doing such
a thing
how he could be such an efficient
predator then the blood sprayed
and her mouth gaped open once then twice
like a fish on a dock
gasping for air her dark eyes seemed to
dim
and then her body rattled and lay still
rafe barely noticed as the spark left he
was fully occupied with the grim task of
tearing her limb from limb
inserting the knife beneath the muscle
tissue and rending it asunder
taking pleasure in the mere fact of
mutilation an unnecessary but satisfying
endeavor
he worked more quickly than usual so the
cuts were sloppier
more ragged much bloodier this pleased
him and he made a mental note of the
fact for future hunts
when he had finished the woman was
little more than a scattered jigsaw of
pulpy flesh
only her face intact her eyes
half-litted and staring
rafe retrieved his branding iron and a
small cigarette lighter from the pocket
of his coat
then with a flourish he pressed the
heated paw print into a tiny square of
exposed skin
he held it there for a moment listening
to the sizzle and savoring the aroma
before pulling the brand away forcefully
as it tended to stick a little
that done rafe took a deep breath
drawing the damp early morning air into
his lungs
he looked down at himself and wasn't
surprised to see that his clothes were
spattered with blood
that was always the way of the predator
he took one last longing glimpse at the
corpse at his feet
then stripped down to his boxer shorts
balling up his bloody clothes into a wad
small enough to fit between his two
fists he could hear
traffic rushing past on the highway to
the left and above him
but he knew no one would be able to see
him from that distance
he tiptoed out of the woods and
slithered back through the fence
keeping his body low so that it was
partially concealed behind a dumpster
in this way he made it back to his car
without being seen
once there the bloody clothes went into
a plastic grocery bag in the back seat
he had brought a clean shirt and jeans
the way he always did on such excursions
he'd always assumed that if mary were to
ever suspect he was up to something
it would likely be because of all the
clothes he went through he had to smile
at that
the smile faded as he started the engine
and slowly made his way back to the
highway
he still had to take care of this second
person and even though the worst of his
hunger had been sated
his anger at being found out was still
raw and seething
he glanced at his watch and saw that it
was only 7 30.
it would only take 20 minutes or so to
get downtown even in heavy rush hour
traffic
he would be waiting for that egyptian
bastard when he came into work
that was certain rafe barely remembered
the drive to the shop
and before he knew it he was pulling up
to the curb in front of the parking
meter
checking to see if his gun was tucked
into the waistband of his pants
it occurred to him then that second
might have copies of the pictures
and that if rafe branded the guy after
he killed him then the cops might tie
the other murders to him
mentally patting himself on the back for
being so clever he left his branding
iron in the glove compartment
still though he might burn the store
down afterwards just in case there was
any other evidence lying around
the streets were jammed with people
today since it was monday
and rafe did his best to blend in with
the crowd
for a moment he became disoriented not
remembering where the store was or what
the number above the door had been
there hadn't been a sign or a business
name of that he was sure tamping down
panic rafe cruised down the street
peering left and right from behind his
dark sunglasses
across the street he could see that
burger joint where he'd stopped
yesterday
so the shop must be right around there
a darkened narrow glass door with a thin
film of dust coating it from inside
and no identifying marks other than
appealing gold 435
stuck in the middle of the transom
tensing every muscle in his body and
poisoning one hand towards his back
where the pistol was
rafe grabbed the metal door handle and
pushed his way inside
it was just like when he had drunk the
tea only this time he was sure
he hadn't had any as soon as he walked
into the shop he was blind
the darkness around him was so complete
that he couldn't even be sure where the
door he had just entered through was in
relation to himself
he whipped his sunglasses off and tucked
them away it made no difference
the smell was stronger too that chemical
smell
and rafe could picture the endless
shelves with their murky bottles
containing christ's new what the panic
was rising again
but he couldn't let it get the better of
him not now he placed his hand on the
butt of the gun and that calmed him
somewhat pulling it out and pointing it
at the nothingness before him calmed him
even more
i've got a gun you son of a [ __ ] he
hissed into the darkness
glad that his voice didn't tremble you'd
better come out if you don't want me to
burn this whole [ __ ] place down
he thought he heard her rustling and he
quickly snapped toward it poking the gun
toward the sound
i can hear you he risked a few steps
forward
almost expecting to feel arms reaching
out to grab him or a blunt object
crashing into his head
nothing of the sort happened so he
risked a few more steps
come out i said his voice echoed back to
him
sounding strange and distorted rafe
the sound of his name was so soft that
he couldn't quite be sure he'd actually
heard it
the darkness seemed to be seeping into
his lungs burning them with the scent of
spices and sulfur
he stopped where he was and a moment
later there was a blaze of light
directly in front of him
so sudden that he threw his hands up in
front of his face
almost dropping the gun in the process
it seemed like there were voices all
around him now
coming from every direction he slowly
moved his hands and blinked in the light
straining to see what was happening the
shop as he remembered it was gone
there was no counter and no apothecary
shelves with rows of old medicines
the space in fact appeared to have
swelled to a hundred times its previous
size
the ceiling cavernous the walls so far
from him that they were barely visible
even in the ample light provided by the
ring of blazing torches that now
illuminated the space
his hands had dropped to his sides as he
stared around the space in awe
the walls were covered in scratches and
letters a longer look revealed them to
be hieroglyphics
at four equal points around him he
noticed massive stone columns
decorated with the same designs
stretching upward seemingly forever
the torches ahead of him flanked a huge
stone table or sarcophagus
on which rested the small weighing
scales he had noticed on the shop's
counter the day before
what the [ __ ] rafe thought still
frightened but more confused than
anything i'm in a goddamn egyptian tomb
rafe he was sure he heard his name this
time
and he snapped his gun back up aiming at
the spot directly in front of him
who's there who indeed secum emerged
from the darkness
his black eyes glittering in the
firelight his skin looked like polish
mahogany
he was naked from head to toe what the
hell is going on here
rafe's gun hand had begun to shake and
he tried to steady it
shoot him some part of his mind screamed
but he couldn't make himself do it
what do you want from me i gave you a
second chance didn't i
sekhim had slithered up behind the
sarcophagus and was standing there with
his shoulders back
very straight his chin raised he looked
regal
and deadly for what what are you talking
about
rafe glanced left and right and saw that
many other people had appeared from the
shadows
mocha skinned and naked watching him
with stern expressions
as the candlelight flickered on their
taut bodies rafe could swear that he saw
them change
saw forms squirming beneath the human
ones
it was this that finally caused the
terror that had been building inside him
to take over
and he whirled around and began firing
wildly into the crowd
the gunshots ricocheted off the stone
walls with high-pitched wines
but none of the assembled throng even
appeared to notice them
at last the hammer clicked on an empty
chamber and he was left standing there
his nostrils full of the smell of
cordite his finger throbbing
sekhim was still regarding him mildly as
if nothing had happened
step forward please he said his tone was
pleasant but there was a definite note
of threat beneath it
rafe dropped the useless gun at his feet
not until you tell me what's happening
here
it was foolish he knew to defy them he
was outnumbered
and now unarmed but he couldn't become
the prey not without a fight
what's happening mr letorno is your
judgment
secum placed a long finger on one of the
scales pushing it downward
causing the other balance to rise he did
this several times
stretching out the suspense until rafe
was almost driven mad
please step forward it will be quicker
rafe's whole body trembled the shadows
around him seemed to be growing deeper
closer as though the people around him
were pressing in for the kill
he didn't want to look at them the
memory of their flickering form
still vivid in his imagination but he
couldn't stop himself and then his
trembling ramped up to screaming
because the people had changed there was
no longer any question of optical
illusion
the woman closest to him had transformed
into a massive black cat
fur shining in sleek and just to the
side of her was a man-sized falcon with
a curving beak
and round staring eyes farther back
he also thought he spotted a monstrous
reptilian thing with rippling green
scales
and an enormous insect with six clicking
legs
rafe scrabbled across the stone floor of
the tomb wanting to run for the exit but
no longer seeing the way he had come in
every other route of egress was blocked
by one of the hideous creatures
bearing down on him with fur and
feathers and scales all glimmering and
wicked
there was nowhere for him to run but
towards secum toward the sarcophagus
as he reached it rafe went sprawling
curling up against the base of the
coffin
and putting his arms up to protect his
face
second make them stop and for a moment
they did stop
standing in a circle before him like the
statues he'd seen in the egyptian
galleries at the british museum
long ago rafe could see now that the
animals were all adorned with gold and
jewels
the cat had gold hoops dangling from her
ears the falcons sported a large neck
plate that appeared to be made of opal
and turquoise
he heard footsteps whispering across the
floor to his left
and he looked up to see sekhem looming
over him an expression of complete
tranquility wreathing his features
he bent down liquidly and forced rafe to
his feet
seemingly with no effort at all it is
proper to show dignity before
your judge he said and although his
voice was quiet it seemed to boom and
echo all around the decorated chamber
rafe's breath was ragged and he kept his
eyes focused on seconds
perhaps if the man felt some pity for
him he might be able to get out of this
mess
look i'm sorry he said not really sure
what he was apologizing for
but figuring it was a good way to start
i'm a bad person i know that
i can try to be better i can try to stop
it
he was babbling he knew and his excuses
sounded woefully lame
but he was desperate already the memory
of the kill this morning had faded from
triumph into something that felt like
shame
look at me and know me said sekhem
pulling himself up to his full height
which was considerably taller than rafe
as the torchlight played across the
man's face
rafe could just see something beneath a
hint of black
a snarl of white canines as he watched
sekhem's human features seemed to melt
into the dimness
his skin darkened from coffee to
polished ebony
and fur rippled forth from some unseen
source
his ears began to lengthen pointing
straight up like those of a doberman
and his face likewise molded forward
forming a long snout
the deep liquid eyes were the only
things that remained the same
and they stared at him with complete
detachment
rafe wanted to turn away but couldn't
wanted to move but didn't dare
the face of a black dog a jackal hung
before him in the darkness
there was a whisper in the crowd and the
shadowed forms pressed closer
animalized twinkling in the light from
the torches
sekhim lowered his head a little as if
indeference
rafe g letorno he intoned though his
black lips didn't move at all
you stand accused of many willful acts
of murder against your own kind
and of taking upon yourself the
trappings of a race you lay no claim to
what do you have to say for yourself on
this matter
rafe could almost hear his knees
knocking together
i know i've done some bad things i don't
deny it okay i'll turn myself into the
police
suddenly this seemed like the best idea
he had ever had
and he grasped at it with fervor would
that make it better
i'll tell the police everything rafe
turned his sweaty face to the others
seeking affirmation or at the very least
pity
you admit the murders you have committed
sekha masked
yes yes i did them all i enjoyed them
even
please let me go i swear i'll do what i
said his voice was a high-pitched whale
and he would have been disgusted at the
sound of it if he hadn't been more
terrified than he'd ever been in his
life
and what of the other charge sekhem's
eyes had not blinked since his
transformation
giving him the appearance of a
disturbingly lifelike wax figure
other charge i don't you purposely made
your killings appear as animal killings
and allowed yourself to be tagged as the
wolfman and the jackal in the media
is this not so yeah i did that i guess
but why sekhim actually moved then
shaking his head a little
and it was as though a sculpture had
come to life
it is a grave transgression to
impersonate one of our kind
in fact it was your mimicry that alerted
us to your activities
you're kind ray flicked wildly at the
gathered multitude
who are all staring at him with glassy
hungry gazes
who exactly are all you people
come now mr letourneau you surprise me a
cold-blooded murderer and pretender you
may be
but i don't believe you're as ignorant
as all that
every word sekhim spoke was stern but
calm with no trace of anger
who do we appear to be mr letorno you're
he looked into second's eyes then found
he couldn't bear the castigation he read
there
even the far away stares of the others
were becoming too much to take
he hesitated to say the words your
egyptian
gods he finally managed looking down at
his hands and mumbling
that is correct eyes you may have
guessed am known as sekimen pet
anpu whip yenpo or by many other names
the most common of which is anubis and
you may also recognize some of my
compatriots
bast the cat horus the falcon sobek the
crocodile
capri the scarab waget the serpent
he gestured to each of the animals in
turn then swept his arm around to
encompass the entire assemblage
we've all gathered here to witness your
judgment you can't do this
the sarcophagus was hard and cold on the
skin of rafe's back
the torches blazed merrily around him
but he still felt as though he was
freezing from the inside
out what can i do to second made a sound
that might have been a sigh
i think that i've been more than fair in
my dealings with you mr letorno
i gave you a warning did i not the
feather of maat
do you remember rafe thought now of the
feather
tucked away in its gold box in his desk
back in a house he would probably never
see again
he pictured mary finding it after he was
long gone and wondering what it was
but i didn't know he cried i didn't know
what it meant you can't possibly
did i not tell you that it was a second
chance
but i didn't understand please
the very act of begging made him almost
sick with self-loathing
but what could he do now he couldn't
escape there were far too many of them
his gun was empty and far out of reach
regardless
then he remembered the gutting knife had
he tucked it back into his boot when
he'd change clothes back at the motel
of course he had he always put it back
in its place he had just forgotten about
it and all the excitement
the bigger issue was would it do any
good the bullets hadn't seemed to upset
anyone
though whether he had actually hit a
single person was an open question
they're going to kill me anyway the
predator's voice in his mind whispered
better to go down fighting than let them
tear me open like a helpless bunny
rabbit
second anubis was still standing there
huge as a tree trunk his black fur
shimmering
rafe glanced up at him then began
blubbering tucking his chin into his
chest
begging for his life in the most pitiful
tone he could muster
he started to crumple to the floor as if
the anguish was too much for him to bear
any longer
and as he lowered himself he felt around
his pant leg with one hand
trying to make the motion look
accidental where was the handle
for a moment he couldn't feel it and his
anguish really did threaten to crush him
but then his fingers brushed across
something hard and he seized upon it
with all the strength he possessed
the plaintive whale emerging from his
throat became a war whoop
as he grabbed the knife and pulled it
free charging forward at the same moment
slinging the blade upward toward the
statuesque anubis
he felt the blade contacting with
something much harder than flesh
and then his whole body was lifted off
the ground by one arm
the arm that held the knife he felt a
vice-like pressure on his wrist and he
screamed as the bones gnashed together
his fingers were pried apart the knife
the only hope of his salvation
snatched away as though it was a toy and
he a naughty child
rafe was dropped to the ground with a
shattering thud then yanked to his feet
again
when he came eye to eye with anubis the
jackal face was ablaze with hatred
the white fangs bared in dripping foam
you dare defy me he roared
hauling rape so close that he could
smell the creature's breath
an overpowering stew of blood and sulfur
the time for discussion is over
your judgment will commence the jackal
let go of rafe
letting him fall bonelessly to the floor
before the sarcophagus
the others bast horus waget crept ever
closer
their animal faces almost appearing to
smile
anubis rounded the stone again and rafe
could no longer see him
a moment later though he heard a booming
voice rise rafe g
letorno rafe didn't think he could rise
his body felt battered and he was sure
at least one of his ankles was broken
but then he saw the other creatures
bearing down on him their claws
outstretched
and the thought of them touching him was
enough to make him struggle to his feet
wincing at the agony that shot up his
legs don't worry about the pain
his inner voice told him helpfully you
won't have to endure it much longer
at last he stood before the sarcophagus
and faced anubis
managing to look the jackal in the eye
the creature's anger seemed to have
dissipated somewhat
though his mouth was still open a little
his teeth still glittering
he said nothing more but placed one
paw-like hand on the small scale in
front of him
pushing it toward rafe a few inches then
he gave a short howling sound
a signal of some sort and another
man-sized black jackal
walking on its two hind legs emerged
from the crowd
in its arms it held a red silk cushion
and in the center of the cushion lay a
tiny ivory feather
the other jackal bowed before anubis who
bowed his own head in return
then plucked the feather reverently from
its bed thank you wep wallet
anubis said wep wallet set the cushion
upon the floor next to the sarcophagus
and sat behind it
settling on his haunches the way a dog
would his ears pricked and alert
anubis held the feather up letting the
fire light play upon its contours
it seemed to glow in his hands and there
was a general sigh from the assembled
creatures
the jackal then brought the feather down
even with his face
the feather of maat he entoned showing
it to rafe
uncertain what he was supposed to be
doing simply looked at the feather and
nodded his approval
his stomach was twisting into knots
moving slowly with the enormity of
ritual anubis placed the feather
lovingly on one of the balances
it lay there white and glowing its wispy
filaments stirred by an unseen breeze
the scale hardly registered its weight
at all
now the jackal's gaze fell upon rafe
again judgment he said we must see how
you measure up in comparison
rafe looked doubtfully at the feather
trying to remember what this ritual
entailed
he knew he'd read something about it
somewhere
what will happen to me if i don't
measure up
there was a long silence even the
whispering creatures behind him seemed
to have gone quiet
at last anubis made a sound that might
have been a laugh
something far worse than you have
endured today i can assure you
with that he raised one massive ebony
arm pointing his strange clawed fingers
toward the ceiling
then his arms shot forward a loud gasp
emerged from all the spectators
rafe felt nothing at first and then
there was a slight pressure in his chest
something like he'd felt a few times
when he'd overdone it at the gym
scowling he looked down at himself
anubis's arm was sprouting out of reef's
breastbone
confused he peered up at the jackal his
mouth opening to ask what had happened
and then the pain hid him full force
obliterating all thought
he found that he couldn't scream
couldn't even catch his breath
his mouth flopped open and closed open
and closed
the torches around him began to take on
strange torturous shapes
illuminating the warped faces of the
animals that swam in and out of his
vision
i'm dying he thought and it didn't seem
such a terrible thing to be happening to
him
all things considered he didn't die
though and as he watched anubis pulled
his hand back toward himself
the fur was matted with blood and the
clawed hand was closed around a scarlet
lump of meat that appeared to be pulsing
that's my heart rafe thought and he
laughed out loud
he looked down at himself and saw a
gaping wound in the middle of his chest
ringed by gobbets of torn flesh just
like one of the girls in the pictures
the memory of his victims all of which
he had loved in his own special way
made him feel exultant and morose all at
once
i'll never finish that puzzle now he
thought bitterly apropos of nothing
and found that he felt like crying the
pressure in his chest was
fading and as he watched he could see
that the flesh was mending itself
stitching back over the wound closing
over his hollow ribcage
after a few moments the hole was gone as
if it had never been there
the shirt over it perfect and buttoned
and bloodless
rafe g letorno rafe looked up at the
sound of his name
anubis was still clutching the heart in
one hand it dripped dark blood under the
stone surface of the sarcophagus
his gaze fixed on rafe the moment of
truth as they say
he placed the heart upon the other
balance opposite the feather
the balance didn't move
there was a stirring in the crowd that
soon grew to deafening proportions
even anubis appeared stunned his hand
frozen in midair
it can't be he whispered wep wawa got to
his feet
swiveling his dog-like head back and
forth as though looking for a traitor in
their midst
rafe couldn't help but stare at his red
still-beating heart
lying there on the scale as if it
weighed nothing at all
the feather fluttered opposite seemingly
unconcerned
does this mean i can go there was more
shouting among the assembled and finally
anubis raised his arm for quiet
the voices ceased immediately i don't
understand what's happened here
he looked up at rafe as if expecting an
explanation
this is impossible slowly rafe began
feeling like himself again
feeling like the predator was again
coming to the fore
he gestured to the scale in front of him
well there it is
maybe not as impossible as you thought
perhaps we could just
begin wep wowwood silence roared anubis
web wowwet blanched and dropped to the
floor curling up next to the cushion
again
his pointy ears drooping the ritual is
very clear
the jackal said in a lower voice he must
go to the kingdom of the dead
but how can he perd bast who slinked
forward on her large black pause
after what he's done the crimes he's
committed
i don't understand it either anubis shot
back clearly irritated
but the feather of ma'at does not lie
wait a minute
said rafe holding up both hands almost
forgetting that his heart had been
extricated and now sat like a bloodied
pot roast on the scale between them
you mean i have to go to the kingdom of
the dead anyway even after i passed the
test or whatever
you didn't think we were actually going
to let you live did you
anubis said with stinging sarcasm he
can't go to the kingdom of the dead said
horus
clicking his beak with something like
indignation it is only for pure souls
his very presence will corrupt the
entire place
yes i'm aware of that thank you anubis's
temper was clearly rising again
rafe thought he saw steam curling from
his black nostrils
might i suggest something rafe's empty
chest was filling with something like
triumph
seeing that he could conceivably take
the upper hand a deal in other words
bast made a hissing sound but anubis
simply looked at him
a deal yeah i don't pretend to know much
about what's going on but it's pretty
obvious i'm giving you a big headache
anubis didn't answer but rafe thought he
saw the creature nod his head
almost imperceptibly right well here's
the thing
you guys don't want me to go to the
kingdom of the dead because i'm so evil
i'll mess it up
you also can't send me well wherever you
were going to send me when you thought
my heart would be heavier than your
feather there
your version of hal i'm guessing and as
it happens
i didn't really want to go to either
place get to the point human
horus growled so what i'm thinking rafe
continued his voice
taking on a chatty tone since it's clear
you won't just let me go and forget all
about me
is that you make me one of you guys you
know half animal god-like
shape-shifter the whole shebang the
outraged voices immediately swelled into
a cacophony
and this time anubis had difficulty
quieting everyone down
once he had he considered rafe with a
look in his eyes that might have been
grudging respect
i'm not entirely sure you know what
you're asking the jackal said
it can't be any worse than any of the
other things you were going to do to me
right
rafe managed to smile his confidence
returning
made a sound that might have been a
laugh at this last pronouncement but
shut up when anubis shot him a dirty
look
what you say is true rafe g letorno the
jackal said thoughtfully
you're not seriously considering his
offer the fur on bath's back was spiked
straight out and her teeth were bared
it would neatly solve the present
dilemma anubis said
it would solve nothing said capri
pushing to the fore
with his segmented legs his speech was
punctuated with buzzes and clicks
we would still be forced to put up with
him for an eternity no less
many of the others murmured their
agreement oh come on
rafe said sweeping his gaze around i'm
not such a bad guy
they all stared at him their black
animal eyes blazing
the fact that you are such a bad guy is
why we are in this mess to begin with
anubis said with acai horus what do you
advise
the falcon bowed his head personally i
think it's preferable to him polluting
the kingdom of the dead
i must say the prospect of having to
interact with him on a daily basis is
not a pleasant one
but the decision lies with you you're
the guardian
indeed i am the jackal seemed resigned
he took one last look down at the scale
that impossible balance of feather
and heavy heart then fixed his gaze on
rafe
very well your wish is granted all right
he couldn't help gloating turning his
head to look at the others
silently rubbing his victory in their
faces every one of them looked as though
they'd like to murder him on the spot
but he knew they wouldn't hurt him not
now he turned back to anubis
do i get to pick what animal to be the
jackal looked as pained as an animal's
face could possibly look
if you must he said smiling rafe
considered his options
although he knew immediately what his
choice would be how could it be
otherwise
thinking of the puzzle he would never
finish the wolf's paw branding iron he
the wolf's paw branding iron he carried
in his jacket he said
i'd like to be a wolf anubis nodded
i figured as much he said rafe pointed
to his heart
still congealing in its puddle of blood
do i get that back
no you will no longer need it as if to
reinforce his statement the jackal
picked up the heart
and took a massive bite chewing it
almost reverently before tossing the
remains to wep wallet
who leaped after the meat with feverish
rapture the wet sounds of the animal
eating echoed around the walls of the
tomb
and now anubis said raising his arms
again
you become as we are rafe closed his
eyes and waited
thinking of the endless years of prey
before him thinking of the mark he would
leave on every one
with his own clawed hand
you